hey everyone my name is Jake I'm here
with Jordan and a couple days ago we had
the opportunity to play a good chunk of
Assassin's Creed Odyssey we played about
the first 8 or so hours I'd say yeah
from start to that point it was the
first time we actually got to see a big
chunk of gameplay like in context as
opposed to just slices that they showed
before right I guess just what did you
think of it overall like you're an
assassin's Creed fan did you like it is
it is it what you wanted yes it was a
pleasant surprise I was going in with
mild expectations because I wasn't the
biggest fan of origins I know a lot of
people are like origins was a revolution
for the franchise and I felt like it was
but at the same time it didn't truly
change enough about the formula really
it got like halfway there right yeah it
was like sort of approaching witcher
type mechanics and whatnot but not fully
embracing them I think Odyssey takes
those few extra steps to really like get
to the meat of what that formula and
mechanics are all about yeah there's
actually a surprising amount of new
features in this game some are small
some are actually pretty big like I'm
sure if you were following this game but
all you know that you can there's
narrative choices this time around and
there's romance and I think that is
something that is interesting especially
considering anthem won't have any
romance options which Bioware has
historically done it all almost all
their games so we got to kind of play
around with that we got to flirt with a
couple people it was kind of weird I
wasn't sure how I felt about it
it was very strange because it felt like
the romance was almost kind of centered
around Cassandra slash Alexios like it
wasn't really about the other person it
felt like in my opinion like a Mass
Effect romance where it's kind of like
you get to pick who you want to be with
and you can almost do no wrong like you
and I both had that pretty much the same
experience when we romance this one girl
there was a scene where eventually you
could make love to her and have the nice
fade to black transition kept
Skinner super on-the-nose to be like hey
before we do this do you want to relax
yeah and then she's like no sorry III
can't think about this right now
anything like my dad is sick yeah and if
you like collect berries for her
something like that you come back like
you want to do this now and she's like
oh no I can't you have to like we have
to get clues and then you get back and
like you want to do this now and then
she's like okay fine I mean and then you
do it and like it cuts to black and like
they kiss or whatever and then it goes
back out and then you immediately have
the option to do it again and if you say
it again she's like man I'm too tired
it's just like it seems so force and I
felt like a big creep like especially I
don't know yeah I was funny I wanted a
bit more of what you see in like The
Witcher so to speak where like if you do
the wrong thing and you come off the
wrong way like the people you're trying
to woo will be like look this is not
working and yeah felt obviously The
Witcher is not like a true romantic
relationship it's still a video game but
like it offered that a bit more realism
to it this just feels really weird like
got to be an overt creep to attract
people that you want and then also the
other thing that are one of the big
changes with combat that really stuck
out with me were the skills so the
combat is very similar to Assassin's
Creed origins little changes here and
there but one of the big things are
skills which allow you to either I think
it's hold left trigger and you hit a
face button and you'll do a special move
with your bow I think right and then
it's left bumper for left bumper to
throw for a physical one and it kind of
remind me of God of War you know you can
unlock runes then allow you to I don't
remember exactly how they went but
basically was something like that like
it was a special move that you could
assign right change mm-hmm
I must say what skills did you so I went
with the the shield destroy or whatever
which is so useful I thought that was a
lot of fun and it's really satisfying
like seeing your character stick it in
the shield and yank it out from all
right and that was one I use the most
and then I also used the rush hmm yeah
the rush was really good my two
favorites were
the Spartan kick which I think Ubisoft
really wants people use I found quite a
few were just chilling on the edges of
ledges I'm like your sole purpose is to
be kicked off this ledge but I also
really liked this weird one that was
like you would throw a knife at someone
if you were in stealth and you would
instantly just appear behind the person
yeah it would cut up close and maybe
they're right it was almost and it's not
like magical but like you would just
like appear next to them yeah just kill
them and you could chain that attacked
it okay well I mean in the demo we had
you could only chain it to do two
different people but I asked the devs
I'm like oh no you'll be able to chain
this to do like three or four people in
like one swift execution like that's
awesome
yeah and then finally I think one of the
biggest things that is returning to
Assassin's Creed is all of the naval
combat mm-hmm and we didn't at least I
personally didn't spend a lot of time
apart from the introduction to it where
you first get your boat which I don't
think we're allowed to give the details
on that but once you first get your boat
you're kind of you know they show you
the ropes and it it it felt pretty good
I think it seems maybe it you just
haven't unlocked maybe we just didn't
unlock it but it seems a little bit more
limited than Black Flag like I remember
having more like piracy options like I
wasn't able to bore at least like you
know how you could if you almost wrecked
a boat in Black Flag you could pull up
next to it and board and then you come
on I didn't do that I don't know if you
can or maybe yeah you can you still can
yeah I did it by accident cuz in that
mission you're supposed to destroy the
ship I think but I
oh but you bought it I did yeah I bought
it by accident I pretty quickly yeah it
was so under levels compared to the
people who are on that ship but so do
you like the do you think the ship
combats working out pretty well do you
think it fits this game I mean it's one
of those things that I realized that
this is further back in time so there's
not as much technology to work with but
it's clearly apparently don't have as
many options at your disposal for naval
combat and the ships are just slower
because again like technology hasn't
yeah hot up to the time in Assassin's
Creed Black Flag again I didn't notice
that like you could hold X or a on Xbox
to like boost your ship but it didn't
last
that long and when you weren't there
like travel speed it was like like how
far do I have to go yeah so I don't know
how that's going to turn out it was one
of those that when the game asked me if
I wanted to do extra bounties on the
ship I was like I think I'm gonna hold
off on yeah so hopefully there's
something to speed up your ship in the
full game otherwise I might not tackle
many of those missions yeah I'm not sure
if I will either I bet but you can't
upgrade your ship throughout the game
and another interesting thing is that
you can also abduct people and like
recruit them for your own ship which
reminds me a lot of like Metal Gear
Solid 5 how you would do that it I don't
think it's as in-depth I didn't spend a
lot of time looking at it but it seemed
like a kind of interesting little touch
yeah it's really weird how you do you
just knock someone out and then you're
like you're coming with me now and
they're like okay I'll join your crew
but I did check and like you can take
the people that you recruit and turn
them into lieutenants and each one of
them has like a specific skill set like
if you recruit an archer then you'll be
able to fire more arrows when you're
boarding a ship and the people that you
romance if you follow their quest line
all the way through you can recruit them
as a lieutenant on your ship as well
like the girl that we were romancing she
has really decía so theseus Edessa
Odessa yeah I was like oh yeah yeah it's
a really good skill like if you make her
oh really
lieutenant on your ship cuz after you uh
after you sleep with her and then she's
like now I don't know what to doing
you're like well you're looking for
adventure hop on my boat and then all
right cool romance is anything else you
wanted to point out that you noticed you
enjoyed or maybe like some concerns that
you might have with it
I will say something that surprised me
is the fact that not all of the swear
words are censored in this game oh yeah
you pointed this out because in the
previous ones usually they do it in like
the language that the area is yeah yeah
language but Cassandra and Alexius they
dropped some f-bomb yeah I do remember
that that was a little bit off-putting
but yeah I don't know like after a
couple time like it's not overused I
didn't think but it definitely was like
oh wow no they are cussing yeah and like
sailors it kind of ties into thing that
we were told right before playing where
Cassandra and Alexios are their own
character like they fit a mold that
Ubisoft has already written so even
though you have those dialogue choices
most of them are just different versions
of the same phrase like you're not
saying totally different things like in
Mass Effect or Dragon Age where you
could say like one thing or a completely
different thing in Assassin's Creed
Odyssey you're saying pretty much the
same thing like there's a woman who asks
you to help her gather some wood and you
can tell her after she keeps nagging you
like look fine it'll get your would just
be patient or you can just go off on her
and like just we're up and down it's
like stop it I will get you away I'll
find you you're kicking wood yeah all in
all though I'm pretty positive on it I'm
looking forward to it I I think what you
said early on is it definitely rings
true I think this game like takes that
final step that origins needed mm-hmm in
order to like feel like a true RPG right
but I don't know we only played the
first 80 or so hours so there's still a
lot more to see but anyway that's what
we thought of the opening hours of
Assassin's Creed Odyssey the game comes
out October 5th 2018 for Xbox one PC and
PlayStation be sure to come back to
GameSpot for all your Assassin's Creed
news
[ __ ] get down here
Cyclops got a message for you tell your
boss he can stick it Thanks for last
week Malaka